so Pete I love the way breakpoints and
media queries are giving us control over
our CSS Styles you know you've had a lot
of experience in the past building
responsive sites what patterns or
general strategies have you found to be
the most useful you're right there are
several great patterns out there but
I'll start with probably the most simple
and one of the most important ones the
grid fluid system with the grid fluid
system columns end up wrapping to the
next line as the browser width starts
getting smaller there's a lot of good
examples out there that you can try like
bootstrap or the 960 pixel grid layout
system that are easy to use and have
everything done for you already well
that does sound like a pretty nice
flexible strategy you know I did a
little searching and I found that the
html5rocks page is an example of a site
that uses a fluid grid notice how when I
shrink the screen the articles that are
three columns across in this main
section shift down to a single column
also if you're unfamiliar with
grid-based layouts or you think you'd
have a hard time designing one of your
own in the intro to HTML and CSS course
we cover grid-based layouts check out
the link in the instructor notes to
learn more